albert goldman tu es célèbre pour ton
livre sur lenny bruce
mais surtout pour le livre que tu as écrit
sur elvis presley
et maintenant tu as un très beau
succès
avec celui que tu as écrit sur john lennon
et qui est je pense numéro deux aux
états maintenant
[Musique]
combien d'exemplaires avez-vous vendu mais je ne sais pas
qu'ils en ont fait peut-être euh
trois cent mille mais combien ils en
vendent
ouais dans votre livre nous avons appris que quand
il jouait à hambourg
à l'époque du star club
john anon avait  une bagarre avec un marin
et il l'a tué non ce n'était pas une bagarre
ils sont allés agresser le marin ouais
pour prendre l'argent parce qu'ils n'avaient pas
d'argent pour manger pour
se réchauffer il faisait froid et jean
s'est mis en colère et a frappé le marin  très dur
et plus tard il s'est inquiété peut-être qu'il l'a laissé
pour mort
mais il n'y a aucune preuve que cela se soit
produit
mais il s'est inquiété d'être coupable ouais il
pensait l'avoir tué
il avait peur de ça avez-vous lu le
meilleur livre de Pete à ce sujet
oui et nous avons interviewé  pete aussi pete était
le premier dr  ummer on devrait dire ah
oui très célèbre en son temps maintenant une histoire triste
ouais et on a aussi appris dans votre livre
que
john lennon était homosexuel et lui maintenant il a
eu une aventure avec
brian epstein oui je ne dirais pas
homosexuel parce que ça implique qu'il aimait
hommes seulement ouais il aimait surtout les femmes
mais euh oui avec le manager il en
avait un si vous en êtes sûr john l'a dit
et il en a discuté avec plusieurs personnes
il a dit que je dois avoir le contrôle de l'
homme
qui nous contrôle c'est pourquoi
mais  je ne pense pas que c'était une question de
sexe je pense que c'était du pouvoir
même si ton livre ne plait pas tellement
aux fans des beatles
pour qui john lennon était un héros
ils le seront et pour toi aussi je pense
qu'ils le feront  être très
heureux de lire sur yokono parce que pour vous,
vous
savez, c'est pire que la parabole,
elle est aussi très drôle bien que je pense
un peu
absurde avec la magie
et avec tous les trucs et
manipulations vous connaissez
un personnage un peu comique je pense
juste derrière moi ouais le  lunettes chics
vous  s
euh sorte d'absurde vous savez faire
tant de mal pour
obtenir un si petit résultat est de la comédie et pourquoi
avez-vous choisi john lennon après lenny
bruce et elvis presley eh bien je l'ai toujours
beaucoup admiré et j'ai senti que
je voulais quelqu'un qui était le plus grand
de  tous ces gens et
nous avons passé des années et des années sur les six
ans et demi
douze cents interviews un demi-
million de dollars ouais
nous avons tout fait pour en faire la recherche la plus
approfondie de l'histoire de la
biographie des célébrités, mais pourquoi choisissez-vous
toujours des gens
qui  sont morts et donc ils ne peuvent pas
bien se défendre vous ne pouvez pas écrire la
vie d'un homme tant qu'elle n'est pas terminée vous savez que c'est
comme un livre il doit être complet
mais pourquoi paul mccartney a-t-il réagi si
violemment à votre livre
je pense que paul est comme je dis toujours qu'il est
comme l'anglais maurice chevalier
ouais toujours soleil ciel bleu
heureux il n'aime rien de
désagréable c'est mauvais pour l'image ouais pour
toi c'était mauvais
aussi c'était mauvais pour nous tous ouais et pourquoi
d  si vous refusez de
répondre aux journalistes de Rolling Stone
auxquels j'ai eu l'impression que
newsweek a répondu à ces gens
et a montré qu'ils étaient
tous des imbéciles d'une manière que vous connaissez jan wenner
qui possède une pierre roulante
c'est l'ami le plus proche de yoko qu'ils
voyagent  ensemble ils font tout
ensemble donc naturellement il va le
défendre il y a un truc dans ton livre
il y a une photo
où tu montres les beatles avec le
marashi
ouais et tu dis y'a deux
inconnus et en fait c'est mon matos
avec les paul's  frère et patty boy
qui était la petite amie de george donc si vous
lisez un livre de
700 pages sur john lennon et quand nous
disons mike mon équipement
et patty boy et vous dites l'
inconnu c'était un éditeur d'images a fait cette
erreur
ouais je sais que je ne le fais pas  écris les euh les
légendes
ouais je n'écris pas les au dos
du livre
j'écris seulement dans les deux tu vois ce que je
veux dire oui bien sur c'est pareil
il y a plusieurs de ces petites
erreurs donc il faut cor  rectifiez-les maintenant
est-ce la même chose dans la copie américaine oh
oui c'était la même erreur
il y avait des erreurs mais quand vous
écrivez tant de milliers et de milliers de
mots de petites choses s'insinuent comme ces
choses stupides
est je pense que votre livre est le nec plus ultra
paroxysme
du nouveau journalisme et on ne
comprend pas pourquoi les gens de Rolling Stone l'ont
attaqué parce qu'en fait c'est un
nec plus ultra du nouveau journalisme c'est à dire
quand tu cherches quand tu regardes
quand tu cherches à obtenir des informations
sur la vie privée de  les gens
à la fin vous venez à votre livre
j'ai toujours eu euh acceptable pour rolling
stone ils ont publié des parties d'elvis
ouais mais quand il s'agit de yoko euh tu
sais c'est tu penses qu'ils sont vraiment des
amis proches oh je sais
bien sûr ils vivent ensemble  en vacances
ce genre de chose donc
je dois être mauvais en pierre roulante pouvez-
vous encore écouter
le disque de john lennon oh j'adore ça
parce que la musique est
euh toujours la plus forte de cette période
ça dure
plus longtemps que n'importe lequel des  les autres albert
goldman dites-moi
qui est le prochain albert goldman est le prochain et
maintenant je tourne l'
objectif sur moi ouais j'écris encore un livre
je n'ai jamais fini de parler de mes années avec les
trafiquants de drogue en amérique du sud en
colombie
et en floride deux et un  Pendant des années et demie, j'ai fait des
allers-retours avec eux pendant
qu'ils apportaient la drogue en Amérique,
mais j'ai dû attendre qu'ils meurent tous
jusqu'à ce que je ne puisse pas écrire
ça parce
que tant qu'ils étaient en vie, je ne pouvais pas
dire la vérité
[Musique]
sur